this week on case studies with the biz
doc it's take-two interactive there is
another side to take to that would
blossom at this time and it was 2k
sports about the same time they
established 2k sports now you have
Rockstar and 2k as part of that they
acquired from Sega the rights to the
ESPN title on sports games so things are
now forming for take two you've got two
K and a bunch of great titles featuring
ESPN branding and you've got Rockstar
doing very well with grand theft auto so
we can look back and see the seeds of
greatness reformed with Rockstar and 2k
but here we are in a five with the SEC
showing up because of what you did when
your company was young well in oh six
long about the end of oh six
fourth-quarter sometime Brandt says oh I
got a bad back well I must have been the
weight of the lawsuit from the SEC and
so he leaves the company and then no7 he
pleads guilty so he leaves the company
gets his house in order decides how he's
going to plead pleads guilty he was
offered up to four years in prison as
part of the plea deal and he said no no
I'll cooperate with you as you're
prosecuting these other guys if you'll
play it down and you never want to be
indicted by the SEC or have their
friends the FBI come after you because
they might offer you the prison shower
expansionpak which is a multiplayer game
you don't want to be a part of